la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Claude
Lenoir ministre monsieur le ministre de
l'Écologie du Développement durable
énergie vous avez la parole mon chers
collègu bien monsieur le Président je
retiens votre premier
lapsus je crois que vous avez dit
Monsieur le noir ministre c'est ça mais
après vous avez rectifié encore j'ai
accueill monsieur le ministre monsieur
le Président je vrais d'abord remercier
monsieur le ministre d'avoir pris la
peine de se déplacer ici au Sénat pour
répondre à ma question ainsi qu'à celle
de mes collègues c'est pour moi
l'occasion d'être honoré par la présence
d'un ministre qui VI d'être renommé et
qui je crois s'exprime pour la première
fois au Parlement devant la Haute
Assemblée ma question monsieur le
ministre porte sur les compteurs
communicquant qui porte un nom qui est
compteur
Linky je suis avec mon collègue Ladislas
spatovski l'auteur d'un rapport qui a
été présenté au gouvernement en
septembre 2011 sur ce sujet de quoi
s'agit-il en quelques mots il s'agit
d'introduire dans notre système de
distribution un nouveau type de compteur
qu'on a appelé intelligent puis
communiquant et qui aujourd'hui d'un
point de vue industriel s'appelle
compteur Linky euh c'est un compteur qui
a un certain nombre de vertu de qualité
il permet d'abord à l'usager au
consommateur de mieux connaître sa
consommation de la suivre euh d'adapter
son mode de consommation en fonction des
tarifs euh qui sont proposés le jour la
nuit selon les périodes et d'ailleurs à
mon avis tout cela peut prospérer c'est
d'autre part un un système qui d'un
point de vue industriel a un impact
extrêmement positif ce sont plusieurs
milliards d'euros et on a évaluer même
le nombre d'emplois 10000 qui serait la
conséquence d'une décision qui pourrait
être prise alors pour l'instant la
décision n'est pas prise de lancer le
compteur limkiy sur le marché français
il y avait eu un certain nombre
d'expérimentations qui ont été menées il
y a eu un certain nombre de personnes
qui ont manifesté leur réticence voir
leur opposition
je pense que ces arguments doivent être
analysés de près mais il faut
certainement aller de l'avant et
introduire le le compteur Linky alors
pour cela il faut une décision et bien
de RDF hein qui est le distributeur mais
je pense que
RDF doit tenir compte de l'opinion du
gouvernement et sans doute de votre avis
monsieur le ministre ce que je souhaite
c'est que très rapidement les
dispositions puissent être prises de
façon à généraliser ce compteur qui je
l'ajoute à vocation à être largement
exporté il faut le savoir un certain
nombre de pays dans le monde attendent
que la France avec ce type de compteur
et bien l'introduise et envisage
également de le mettre aujourd'hui en
France nous sommes donc dans l'attente
dans les pays qui nous entourent je
pense notamment en Europe vous avez
l'Italie qui l'a déjà fait avec je pense
un compteur un peu moins performant
enfin bref nous avons un excellent
produit il y a une décision à prendre
elle est attendue j'ai même cru
comprendre monsieur le ministre
qu'aujourd'hui pourra y avoir des
décisions qui sont prises je veux pas
croire que c'est en raison de la
question orale que j'ai déposé mais
l'opportunité là la coïncidence j'espère
monsieur le ministre que vous allez
pouvoir nous annoncer de bonnes
nouvelles merci mon cher collègue donc
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Martin
ministre de l'écologie développement
durable et de l'énergie bien monsieur le
Président juste un mot pour dire
l'honneur que je ressens d'être ici pour
la première fois à répondre à une
question dans la Haute Assemblée ayant
été pendant des années le
collaborateur le plus proche de Michel
charas euh je sais l'importance de cette
assemblée je tenais à vous dire à
travers vous l'importance que
j'attacherai dans cette assemblée à être
présent attentif aux demandes qui seront
faites et en réponse à aux
sollicitations qui sert celles des
sénateurs monsieur le monsieur le
sénateur Jean-Claude Lenoir que je
retrouve avec plaisir puisqu'il a fait
un passage d'une assemblée à l'autre je
voulais vous remercier bien sûr pour
votre question qui me donne l'occasion
de préciser l'état d'avancement du
projet de déploiement des compteurs
intelligents Linky le principal enjeu de
la transition énergétique qui est
actuellement au cœur d'un débat national
celui qui d'ailleurs fait le plus
consensus c'est celui de la sobriété et
de l'efficacité énergétique et il y a
deux composants dans l'efficacité
énergétique l'une passive c'est le cas
de la rénovation énergétique qui donnera
lieu à un programme ambitieux mené par
Madame Duflot l'autre actif c'est-à-dire
le fait que la consommation puisse être
pilotée et rendue j'allais dire
intelligente par ailleurs les objectifs
de développement des énergies
renouvelablebl très souvent
intermittentes nécessiteront un système
électrique beaucoup plus réactif à même
de mieux les intégrer au niveau existant
un nouveau rapport entre l'offre
notamment les énergies renouvelables et
la demande doit donc émerger et à ce
titre le compteur link Key est appelé à
jouer un rôle déterminant vous l'avez
signalé dans votre question c'est ce
compteur intelligent qui permettra au
consommateurs de piloter leur
consommation et qui permettra le
déploiement des Smart Grids c'est-à-dire
des réseaux intelligents pour le système
électrique en période d'augmentation des
coûts je crois que c'est quelque chose
d'important le projet Linky est un vrai
projet d'intérêt général il profitera
l'ensemble du système d'électricité
comme à chaque foyer français et la
concorttation engagée par le
gouvernement sur le projet Linky a
permis d'avancer significativement
elle a permis d'obtenir une
compréhension partagée de certains
enjeux elle a clarifié les concepts et
le vocabul
cette concertation a également souligné
les forts enjeux industriels français
attachés à ce projet et ses conséquences
bénéfique pour l'emploi dans la filière
électrique comme vous le soullignez
ainsi que pour les exportations ce qui
est très important pour nous le
déploiement des compteurs devrait
débuter d'ici à la fin de l'année 2014
mais au-delà de la décision du Conseil
d'État qui ont validé le dispositif
réglementaire il reste des étap à
franchir pour assurer une maîtrise
optimale du développement du projet le
gouvernement sera attentif et je vous
confirme que que probablement cet
après-midi dans le programme
d'investissement d'avenir le Premier
ministre reviendra sur cette question
qui est partie prenante bien sûr des
investissements à réaliser qui vont dans
le sens de votre question enfin je tiens
à souligner à cette occasion que le même
démarche est mise en œuvre pour le gaz
avec le projet qu'on appelle Gaspard et
qui aura je l'espère les mêmes bénéfices
attendus pour les consommateurs merci
d'avoir posé cette question et de
m'avoir donné l'occasion de dire que le
gouvernement attache énormément
d'importance à ce développement monsieur
monsieur le noir pour répondre à
Monsieur le Ministre oui monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le ministre
pour les informations que vous nous
donnez pour l'intérêt évident que vous
portez à cette question vous l'avez
souligné le le compteur Linky est appelé
à à connaître un grand succès industriel
il faut maintenant passer aux actes
simplement un mot pour souligner un
point que vous avez vous-même évoqué qui
est qu'audà même du compteur Linky il y
a les réseaux intelligents il suffit pas
que la terminaison c'estàdire le
compteur soit intelligent il faut que
l'ensemble euh du réseau puisse
notamment dans la période de transition
énergétique bien répondre au
développement des énergies renouvelables
et donc je pense que les conditions sont
réunies si l'élan est donné à travers
l'édition qui peuvent être pris cet
après-midi je serai monsieur le ministre
le premier à m'en réjouir merci encore